vous êtes en train de dire publiquement
à l'espèce humaine nous ne sommes pas
seuls nous ne sommes pas seuls du tout
les données montrent clairement que ce
n'est pas le cas
nous avons des vaisseaux spatiaux d'une
autre espèce tout à fait combien
vous plaisez non
est-ce que nous avons des corps des
spécimens
évidemment quand on récupère quelque
chose qui atterrit ou s'est écrasé on
risque de tomber sur des cadavres et
croyez-le ou non même si ça semble
fantastique
c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
sur les phénomènes
et enfin la lumière est faite
vous êtes un ignare en la matière bravo
tu as complètement raison bien sûr enfin
on va savoir maintenant Cyril c'est la
prochaine étape cette fameuse zone 51
dans le Nevada il y avait le vaisseau
spatial
avec l'homme de Roswell les Américains
l'ont gardé pour faire des études
militaires tout ça sera transparent
enfin quelqu'un à vous et moi je suis
très content parce que les
extra-terrestres sont là il faut bien
les accueillir et moi j'ai envie d'aller
dans la zone 51 les chercher tu vas en
prendre combien chez toi qui vole si en
plus c'est des squatteurs la vidéo qu'on
vient de voir vous avez vu ce qu'il a
dit là répétez ce qu'il a dit ils sont
là
[Musique]
c'est un vétéran de l'armée de l'air pas
du travailler au engie et qui en fait
une antenne dans ta gueule et une
antenne une antenne du Pentagone c'était
un conseiller technique pour phénomène
aérien et au départ il a déjà il avait
déjà fait une première alerte qui était
en juillet 2021 sur des infos classiques
classifiés et après il a remis d'autres
infos en mai 2022 à la Direction du
renseignement
dans la bouche
et maintenant donc il s'est dit non
parce que justement il estime que que
les députés ne sont pas au courant et
donc il veut mettre ça
moi 13 millions d'Américains qui
trouvent qu'ils pensent que la terre est
plate voilà tu pourras pas empêcher ça
mais évidemment ça fait 50 ans qu'on a
des restes de vaisseaux spatial qu'on a
un câlin et personne n'a montré de
photos personne n'a montré il y a
tellement de gens
pourquoi il y a une cellule pourquoi il
y a une cellule en France pour les ovnis
tu peux lui dire s'il te plaît on
observe l'univers c'est normal
on a une cellule qui s'occupe des objets
volants
identifier qui s'appelle le géant voilà
un budget c'est un budget qui est
rattaché de la défense
ah non mais elle a raison pourquoi on
met des millions d'euros pourquoi et
pareil tout seul on observe mais j'ai
pas déconnecté tout seul mais on n'a pas
la preuve et on a pas de on a encore
moins dans un spatiaux ou de cadavres de
d'extraterrestres comme par hasard ils
ont toujours une grosse tête
les militaires et on peut tous tous les
vaisseaux qui se sont crachés pour
s'accaparer les matériaux et en équiper
mais maintenant
tu vas réveiller Castaldi maintenant
il y a des gens qui disent qu'ils ont
été enlevés par les extraterrestres ils
ont été enlevé pour les a rendus
que depuis des décennies il y a des des
programmes secrets sur mais oui
du matériel du matériel d'origine
exotique c'est ce qu'ils disent et en
fait l'armée travaillerait sur ce sur
ces matériaux les utiliser à des fins
militaires
fidèle c'est pareil on trouve de tout le
théories
mais bon
si tu avais pas ce maudit chewing-gum
dans la merde
en chewing-gum tout le monde me dit que
c'est tout à fait compréhensible
[Rires]
même bien sûr alors moi je regarde tous
les documents faire sur les
extraterrestres j'adore ça j'adore tous
les trucs les phénomènes non expliqués
mais non mais c'est pas comme les
fantômes il y a des milliards et des
milliards qui sont mis en oeuvre pour
étudier ces phénomènes
qui habitent dans le je sais pas quoi
dans une dans une bergerie il va nous
apprendre la vie
il y a des milliers
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
des millions de galaxies on ne connaît
pas qui sont pas explorer donc je vois
pas comment tu peux imaginer
ils ont trouvé des choses justement qui
sont non identifiées qui sont pas
répertoriés sur ça il y a des phénomènes
qui sont inexpliqués les mecs à la NASA
tu crois qu'ils font quoi toute la
journée
vers le ciel les mecs juste pour comme
ça je regarde que ça mais moi j'adore ça
genre toutes les enquêtes
à chaque fois j'aime trop il y a des
trucs dessus
[Rires]
moi ce que je comprends pas
pour les emmener là-bas pour faire des
et moi je suis persuadé qu'il y en a un
parmi nous parce que lui
c'est lui là-bas il y a que lui il va
normal en plus quand vous dites que
c'est secret c'est pire que ça c'est
vraiment ce monsieur il a pris le statut
de lanceur de l'arc parce qu'il a été
menacé exactement
c'est un sujet qui dérange